Coming back to our zombie walk, you know, we're pretty happy with the lower body, but
I think maybe we should experiment a bit more with the upper body and with the arms.
So for that we're going to use the layered blend per bone node.
Now this allows us to selectively blend different animations together on different parts of
the body.
So we could split up the body into different groups of bones, giving us a really easy way
to separate things like the upper and lower body or the arms and the legs and just affect
those parts of the body with the animations that we want.
In our anim graph, I'm going to right click and search for layered blend per bone and
bring in our layered blend per bone node here.
I'll also bring in the creep walk, which is, if I remember rightly, the basis of our zombie
animation and connect that to the output pose and tick looping.
And if we compile, there we go, we have our creep walk playing.
I'm then going to bring in our full loop animation because if I double click this to open it
up, I know it has some upper body animation on there, but I think it adds some coolness
to the zombie walk.
So if I plug that into our blend pose is zero pin and set that to looping again and compile,
you can see that it's not yet having an effect on our animation.
And that's just because we haven't defined which bones we want the animation to play
on yet.
So selecting our layered blend per bone node again.
In the details panel under the config heading, we have layer setup.
And inside there, we've got index zero.
Now this is relating to our blend poses zero input pin.
If I was to hit add pin, you'll see we get a new index.
So when you want to blend multiple animations together, that's how you do it, but we'll
take a look at that in a bit.
So under this index heading, we have branch filters where we can add multiple branches
and split this animation into different parts of the body or apply it to different parts
of the body.
So if I hit a plus there, we add a new index and I'm going to give it the name of the first
bone in the chain that we want to affect.
And because we want to affect the upper body, I'm going to give it spine 04.
So that's going to affect the upper chest and everything above that.
So if I compile, you can see on the lower body, we have the creep walk playing.
And then the upper body, the fall loop, because we have our alpha set to one, that's going
to play 100% of the fall loop animation.
So if I was to change that to 0.5, for example, you can see that we're now blending half of
that animation and we've got some of that creep walk movement underneath.
Now this is looking kind of cool, but I think we can get something a little better if we
break the body up into a few more pieces.
So back into our layered blend per bone node, I'm going to add another pin here, duplicate
this fall loop animation with control D and connect that to our blend poses one pin because
I still like the way that this fall loop animation is affecting our pose and our animation, but
I want to break it up so that perhaps we have a different strength of this animation on maybe
the arms compared to what we have on the spine.
So we now have this new index here and under the branch filters, I'm going to add two new
branches, one for each arm.
So our start bone name is going to be clavicle L for the left arm and bone name for the right
arm clavicle R. So if I compile, as you can see, because our blend strength, our blend
weight should I say is set to one, we're getting 100% of that fall loop animation on the two
arms and 50% of the animation on the spine.
So I could tweak this again to something like 0.7 maybe and then compile.
So we still get some of that underlying creep walk animation on the arms, but we also have
the interesting pose from the fall loop.
Now this is looking kind of cool so far, but the head is maybe looking a little too stable
and I think with zombies they're always a little bit wobbly and maybe the head is like
snapping at you trying to bite you and something that I would think would work quite well for
that is the run forward animation because this has got a lot more movement in it and
a lot more action going on.
So if I add a new pin and plug that into blend poses to and just make sure we're looping
that animation, I'm going to cut off the head and just apply this run forward to the head.
So if I just shrink that down these two indexes and opened upon newest and add a new branch,
I'm going to use neck underscore 01 because I know that that's the first neck bone and
we're going to affect everything after that, the tip of the head.
So already you can see that's something kind of cool there.
It's maybe a little bit strong, but you can imagine him kind of snapping and biting at
you.
Maybe I can reduce it down to 0.8 perhaps.
Yeah that's looking kind of cool there.
So I think we could probably call the zombie animation done there.
Now you could do the same sort of thing with this animation where you could record it out
and create a loop of the animation again.
You could also open the animation sequencer and bake that down to a control rig which
will give you much more control over the loop making sure that there's no pop and you can
add in any cool little details that you want to add to really polish it up.